right now would you rather be sports
shooting surfing or making more sequels
sports shooting skeet shooting shooting
[Music]
Walgreens is a formidable foe let me
tell you guys right now okay
a formidable foe presses hard Walgreens
doesn't come to my house you know
Walgreens doesn't ask my parents
questions all greens doesn't take words
that I say and then contort them into
something else you almost feel like
people know too much be on the cover of
a magazine very strange because you're
trying to be something that you think
would fit on the cover because my
regular lifestyle is not going to be on
the cover details even Stevens was a
party
people say you lose your childhood doing
a sitcom when you're young and it wasn't
that way from me I'd wake up and have
pie fights for hours you know that was
my life AJ was my best friend I'd sleep
at his house and stay in the motel some
of the best memories of my life from
that show Project greenlight helped me
deal with paparazzi impress you learn
that this show starts when you open your
door show stops when you close your door
and and you're always on the miniatur
out you really can't put in the words
with that hug from Harrison Ford means
there were hugs yeah Ally yeah I mean
not a lot not like like overtly wow
they're hugging a long time or anything
like that I'd say about a hug a month
was the ratio like the the like the once
a month hug men alive and make his great
hugger his babes in toyland et movie
Thailand's only hope
but she'll lead the help of the karate
kids Pat Morita is empty movie it was a
witch in a bowling ball that's kind of
teeny that's a tween movie it Swedish
what was that one with Jennifer Love
Hewitt can't hardly wait I liked that
movie a whole lot
I mean Idol really who put that on the
list teen idol would be like a Jonas
Brother or something they're kind of
teen idol II handsome dudes some
handsome dude like you Jonas Brothers
you kidding me that's all I wanted
that's all I want to be right now I want
to be the fourth Jonas Brother you must
remember to keep the child in you and I
[Music]